welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
it's a little ditty in my heart today
because we are live over at twitch.tv
Ford / H Street productions every Friday
thank you everyone for tuning in today's
episode is sponsored by me unto youth
kaptara
lift and mana creep god bless you also
got some fresh merch up today some fresh
hot merch including but not limited to
vaping Santa Christmas sweater you know
when when Christmas comes I want you to
wear this at your house and freak your
nan out she's gonna say what the hell is
Santa doing young Billy you say Nana you
don't understand you old hag what what
do you tell your parents when you want
to wear this on the holiday it's just a
Santa in the cloud
I think it's innocent honestly we were
torn on it were like is this not is this
too far Santa it's not like Santa
shooting meth it's not Santa with a
heroin needle in this yeah it's vaping
it's a cloudy day it's a cloudy day
vapenation anyway we thought it was a
little bit of a gag so that's up on a
shoe a shoe shop I hope everyone had a
wonderful Thanksgiving appreciate you
all so very much for coming out and
spending your day or evening if you're
in Europe with us what a joy and
privilege it is to share this time with
you god bless you we did have a guest
schedule today Bert Kreischer but he had
to cancel for personal reasons so
blessings to him Papa's blessings to be
specific and work but we're gonna be
kicking out old school me Neela yep top
of the week top at a freaking year
because we have so much to talk about
and some exciting news too
previously we had a calling system
through discord but honestly nobody
knows what the [ __ ] discord is and you
had to be subscribed on Twitch and we
kept getting like the same temp people I
mean bless your hearts and everything
then would explain and as soon as it's
done people would say wait how I
wouldn't be able to figure it out yeah
so here's the great news danke I
actually don't have the phone number we
have a public phone number so anybody
can call it now poor ian is going to be
on the brunt of everyone trying to call
him but he's gonna sort it out dan can
you say the phone number what is
it we're gonna put it on screen right
now hey sit okay great so call this
number if you'd like to engage with us
in any conversation we're alive baby
this is live should we do it first one
like like yeah let's take a call like
right now so calling
anyway I'm really excited about this cuz
it's like a real radio show now you know
we don't have to you know I've been
going like discord yeah so my head story
today that I want to talk about is in
our last episode with post Malone
we were watching a live stream of
Patrice Wilson's and he scared the
living god out of me for those of you
who missed that episode we were watching
he's jumping into screen now what does
that mean
it's gonna look at calls oh yeah he's
getting water how happy is in right now
so in the last episode of you guys
missed it
Patrice Wilson who's someone we hadn't
made videos before in the past he's a
little creepy guy and they all have a
bit of a pedo vibe so this was years ago
I don't know if the guys actually
diddling kids I mean how could I know
that but it's the insinuation yeah
there's never been anything actual yeah
no I think it's a joke right it's a joke
anyway he's deleted all the chump
videos on his channel started a live
stream with our channel name in the
title h3h3 and it was super creepy we
pulled up the live stream on post Malone
was here and the countdown faded to a
shower curtain a live stream of a shower
curtain a really creepy seedy one and it
was like shots of him walking through a
graveyard it kept getting weirder and
weirder after we finished the stream
there was like him walking in the you
know in a dark Street and like mumbling
stoppage to himself
yeah kill I mean at first I was like oh
this is
but then it kept happening and people
were saying in the comments like you
should probably start taking this
seriously like at what point do I
informed the authorities or YouTube or
so on that this guy has lost a couple of
screws and he's coming after me well I
wasn't I wasn't super scared but later I
think it was the next day he had changed
the countdown because it was originally
counting down like 300 hours till
December first at midnight and so he
uploaded a video on his channel and he
changed the countdown to two hours and
he uploaded this video and it scared the
living Christ out of me
well it's so low that you can actually
see the image on this monitor but it's a
it's a graveyard
it's a looping image of a graveyard and
in the description it says Ethan like
before he hadn't called me up I named
the H THC it could have been incidental
maybe part of whatever his uh and he
added a second countdown so there were
two countdowns yeah one was for that day
which was Saturday the day after the
podcast so I'm sitting at home trying to
relax after a long stressful week and
I've got Patrice's livestream open with
my [ __ ] name and a close-up
reoccurring of a rainy tombstone and I'm
thinking to myself I'm freaked okay if
you don't know what this guy looks like
let me show you who the [ __ ] is after me
this is Patrice Wilson peeking in the
window of a 12 year old girl pretending
to be mr. Rogers okay this is who's
after me writing Ethan in the
description dudes okay
so there was a countdown and it was for
like sometime in the evening maybe eight
I was something about and we were at
home yeah and we kept watching it and
just doing whatever we were doing
thinking like maybe it's creepy maybe
it's stupid and then as we kept going
down it was like almost like an hour to
the end of the countdown we started to
get freaked out it was when I saw my
name in that yeah and I was like you
know what this is [ __ ] up this
cool so I'm like illa get your [ __ ]
we're leaving I'm leaving the house I am
NOT gonna get turned into Chinese food
by this creepy guy that's one of his
videos it's a reference it's a it's a
reference it's a I like Chinese yes
so I bounced and I wrote an email to my
contacts at Google and YouTube and I and
I'm so embarrassed by that email cuz I
was genuinely like this [ __ ] is getting
too weird for me to handle and I think I
titled it something like urgent a threat
against my life like that traumatic cuz
I was like I have one minute to leave I
started getting like spice tingles down
my spine I was jittery freaked out
urgent threats against my life and
they're like what like what the [ __ ]
like Ethan's always been insane I
complain to these guys so much like this
this is too much for me every day
there's an urgent email yeah exactly
channel deleted yeah I won't that's it's
a combination of me being an alarmist in
them actually you know appreciate a
platform but probably anyway they got
this email for me and I think I think I
still have it but I'm like this channel
was making threats against my life and
he's got my name of the Todd and he's
doing creepy [ __ ] in this channel it's
like not very convincing unless you were
in it yeah I can only imagine how it was
received is like wow Ethan's really
losing it I'm I'm really deeply
embarrassed because he's my respect they
send this email to I sent that off I'm
freaked out I'm not thinking I'm we get
in the car we drive to a [ __ ] raava's
parking lot and we're sitting there
waiting out the timer like an hour I'm
sitting in Ralph's parking lot I'm like
just playing there's people around us
right and then I was expecting to like
come out the back seat yeah
and then it came on and he had like a
creepy voice I've got the video up so
the countdown finally expires let's take
some calls after this oh wow we have a
lot holy smokes trying to understand
this okay still screening this could be
our ghost story even though there's no
ghosts of all the treats as the ultimate
ghosts
dan I thought we were only supposed to
have eight College but there's like
thirty here anyway so the countdown
expires I'm sitting in my car in the
Ravis parking lot shittin bullets
looking over my shoulder and this is
what comes on Patrice's livestream
[Music]
meanwhile I'm sitting in my car like you
sit there meanwhile I'm sitting there in
my car like this is so stupid like what
is my life right now like listening to
Patrice Wilson talk about bowling with
the pitch shift on his voice like this
guy got my head Patrice Wilson dude but
anyway I ended up like saying and if you
think that this is about going to
someone's house about trying to kill
them get that idea out of your head you
guys this was a huge drama like the BOD
of us happening through this live with
post has like a million views this was a
huge ordeal there was a whole team of
crack investigators on it yeah that was
amazing
well we'll explain what they found out
but I want you guys to watch this it's
no different than what you see on TV the
violence you see in the wall today you
think it's no different
she watched I love the sound of pepper
Jorge was going wrong the world I want
to find the part where does your brother
film is enough I would not take violence
even in the situation
hey come on get here he goes he's saying
everyone watched and was just thinking
something vulgar and negative when I was
like I was only walking through a
graveyard but somebody's name has made
fun of me in the title I was just saying
there myself stop it and kill stop it
kill h3 I want to kill I want to wanna
[ __ ] Ethan's dead party everyone's so
vulgar jig so I'm gonna wake up in like
a you know it's gonna happen we're gonna
wake up one morning and we're gonna be
inside the dollhouse that that Alison
gold music that it was right peace
inside that'd be pretty cool to see the
set yeah until like all the sudden he
starts Dave raping you everything you
just went up in that video so story
first yes
so I suggest that you keep on digging
finding the clues while you doing it
[Music]
stay positive
anyway you know he's real inspiring and
all that good job good job Patrice you
got me out of my [ __ ] house on a
Saturday night it was the first time in
months I'll say that at least anyway so
yeah I was like he's not trying to kill
us apparently what didn't he say that
mm-hmm to disarm us have the decency to
stay positive
so all these crack detectives went to
work to try to decode this and here let
me show you this the investigators yeah
the investigators let's see they were
like up one Dischord all night let me
read this one of the discord detectives
checking in so since the HP podcast last
night over 300 people joined in the
official patrece countdown discord Ethan
locked the doors and get out and go get
in the parking lot of Rob's your life's
in danger cryptic live stream from
Patrice around 15 of the dedicated
members formed the detectives who worked
around the clock and constantly dug up
the location Patrice was walking around
so he showed himself in the gray very
show himself walking around a house with
ladders and [ __ ] I'm gonna assume mostly
have you seen the video yet yada yada so
these these rain men god bless them they
found exactly on Google Maps satellite
images where in the country it was they
identified all the locations yeah that
he was showing so he wasn't in LA so
that was a little bit of a was a little
bit of a relief but then he says hold on
our original leads were to trap what is
the shower curtain video and what's
moving behind it where was the cemetery
who was walking around where was the
road he walked down where was the house
we walked around for the first few hours
this was all we had but the detectives
quickly found the path he walked down
the house we walked around in the semi
he was at but we couldn't find the link
then Patrice leaked a couple more videos
a girl running through a force being
shot at holding a baby doll and then him
sitting in a dark room seemingly talking
to voices in his head saying stupid
Billy Shh while the negativity brighten
up there's clearly nothing sinister
going on here this videos were
transcribed in the names were researched
for links to Patrice who were Eric Billy
Michael Chris and Matilde were they his
kids his dogs his children they may
never know but there was a breakthrough
they were digging through domains under
his name turns out the guy owned some
really strange ones including my eye
girl dot Network my eye girl network com
what's an eye girl it's a whole new
genre his name also came up on a website
called Sonic media networks Sonic media
networks is not owned by Patrice but is
producing a show for them with a little
digging revealed they have posted a
couple of trailers on Vimeo for a horror
show they're releasing on Amazon called
vantage points couple trailers showed up
they found them it's the same curtain
it's the same girl running through the
[ __ ] stairs you know running through
the woods and there was also a
silhouette of my body it's riddled with
holes and stab wounds every trees
putting his name am i decapitated neck
I've been watching too many minehunters
it was so so was solved and the guy was
just doing a little bit of a gimmick tip
to promote his Horror Show and on one
hand like I don't really appreciate him
using our name for publicity and
freaking me out like that mm-hmm
but on the other hand I guess I owe him
one you know we've done enough for
Christ's sake the guy can [ __ ] make
me think I'm gonna be murdered for one
evening fair enough fair enough Patrice
all right what do we got here we got a
call hello hello you're on there what I
like how you doing I'm doing great we're
doing great we love being a pop
something three three it's very
enjoyable
thanks man cool well
thank you good what is your location
going to be when you see the Patrice
Wilson countdown go to zero okay so when
it goes to zero well tell you our
location I can't I can't say it you know
publicly because that's a security risk
but probably at Whole Foods parking lot
hopefully we'll be we'll be in the
feminine hygiene tile of Whole Foods on
Ventura and no we were talking about
that with with post Malone the guy has
guns he's got guns
he's got swords he's got brass knuckles
post Milan yeah he's got a whole frickin
arsenal and he's got bodyguards who are
Samoan he does I'm gonna be there
wherever that is I'm gonna be there um
why is it muted what's going O
are you there what happened he drops
okay thanks for the call dude oh you
okay apparently okay that worked
Ian you should write their name Yeah
right okay cool Dave's question yeah
thanks for the question I guess so the
new system works just worked I mean it
worked so yeah that's that was the
exciting news for me
so anyway lucky to be alive
you know thankful on this Thanksgiving
Day that I am NOT being captivated
captive by Patrice
so moving on wanted to discuss Black
Friday as today's Black Friday you know
what happened to Black Friday like last
night after Thanksgiving my sister was
like oh they're doing Black Friday at
Target I'm like it's not it's Thursday
it's like people can't even get a break
from having dinner with their family it
used to be that these sores had the
courtesy to wait till the next day but
now the pandemonium
that depravity starts right as you put
your fork down like seriously we went
there at 5 o'clock and there was like we
went outside target there was like
leaves everywhere garbage low blood it
was like bloodstains the police were
there I'm like okay I don't even finish
digesting my food and already it's like
the [ __ ] purge down at Target what's
in target by the way nothing literally
what isn't a target that is worth lining
up for they did actually have this which
by the way they had a it's it's also
blood is not an ad it's just the first
time I switch for sell in any store
that's true the funny thing about the
switch was we were we were just there
mostly out of curiosity we were walking
through the store the switch was a
blockbuster Black Friday deal at 299 is
a fulbright what the hell got is scam
you rotting blockbuster
so essentially what Black Friday has
turned into is retail companies tricking
you into thinking you're getting a deal
it's a great turn nation they're not
even giving you deals anymore we're
walking through Target
it's like TVs you know you save 30 bucks
people are buying blu-rays my sister
went there by blu-ray digital media
digital media still a thing
I got a blu-ray unlike my DVDs are
garbage I don't wash those but my
blu-rays are killing it you making fun
of your sister and I may be watching no
she's not watching I've got a blu-ray
you know in ten years there's gonna be
beaming movies right into our brains and
physical media will be left behind when
we're all shrunk you know what's gonna
happen in the future we're gonna run out
of space and we're all gonna be shrunk
into one inch tall you know like a
that's what's gonna happen and we're not
gonna be able to take our blu-rays with
us is what I mean
you know all the poor people will be
huge the rent the rich people will get
shrunk because they have more space it's
like you just watched that trailer
no it's all the idea from Kurt Vonnegut
yeah there's this movie coming home was
it called something I don't know but
they like oops I'm Matt Damon and I got
shrunk yeah
it's about shrunk I shrunk again Oh No
shrunk yeah but it's about Matt Damon
downsizing down and so and like if you
have a hundred thousand bucks you can
get downsized and you get to live like a
king because everything's so cheap when
you're small to live in all tiny little
world just a little tiny Forks but and
they do not have blu-rays the technology
doesn't exist
you can't have a disk this big
everything else works point is who's in
Target buying blu-rays yes yeah my
sisters hits way to close down so I
wanted to celebrate it I I want to
celebrate the act of stomping on a
baby's face to save $10 on a rice cooker
by showing you my favorite Black Friday
compilation videos cool or not I made my
own compilation this is Ethan's finest
wow you're like a DJ on YouTube
I'm a DJ of pushing Nana down and
breaking her [ __ ] hip to save $2 on a
blu-ray that you won't you will throw
out nice play with I get you got to love
the contrast of Thanksgiving to
Thanksgiving you get around with your
family you're so grateful for my love
for the love I have in my life for my
family my friends I'm healthy I'm happy
and then eight hours later you're like
get the [ __ ] outta my way granny I need
to save five dollars on this television
that I'm gonna put in the kitchen cuz I
already have one in all my other rooms
my kitchen needs a TV
I'm thankful for these Black Friday
videos so let's watch one well let me
give you a little twist here this was
actually when I saw from this year they
gave me a giggle there was apparently
Black Friday is just catching on in the
UK and so they just had their first like
stampede in the UK this video absolutely
blew my mind I'm like scared I don't
know that UK's ready for Black Friday
because look at them looking basically
what happens in this retail store when
they opened the doors this shit's gonna
blow your mind let me get that back then
god bless the Englishmen and God bless
that guy too
I saw it coming they're like enjoy the
Black Friday sales he's like what's
Black Friday what's I'm just here for
I'm just here for a pack of gum ok but
let's get to the face stomping let's get
to the point while we're here
enough wholesome [ __ ] let's get to
the American Hunger Games just imagine
if there was a black fighting in Israel
what would happen just here we borrow
polite yeah there be gunshots be an
all-out Civil War man so here we go this
is takes place in Walmart of course
these people act like it's the last TV
on earth maybe it is in their hearts and
minds
[Music]
get that TV boy get that my god get that
monitor I was about to break loose here
guys and only Ken left and ammonia my
friends there goes that team get that
mark do not let that [ __ ]
take that 23-inch telezart yeah the
police have to waste their goddamn time
like I swear to God a Target and Walmart
the police are just like I have to wake
up and early going for my family and
stake out Target or Walmart because I
know my days for them I'm have to taste
someone this morning
Happy Thanksgiving screaming get on the
ground at 5:30 in the target god bless
america
he must be broken
somebody had mentioned that they sell
all the like the electronics that didn't
pass the ins inspection so they have
like the low tier [ __ ] grade electronics
that they pawn off for discount on these
days so they're actually even buying
even shittier electronics man I wouldn't
be surprised you got to get paid by you
know um what do you think this is a
symptom of what's wrong with us what is
wrong with America is this doesn't
happen in other countries what do you
see here what does this mean America is
a special place
thank you yeah
what does it mean people need people
need their TVs right and it's on sale
family there's just some good shows
right now I don't know people don't get
paid enough Americans they don't get
paid enough is this just like this right
well again good is real people get paid
good here compared to Israel I guess the
problem in Israel is that the people who
do the sales are like I'm not putting
this [ __ ] on discount
it's like greed all around I don't know
it's just Black Friday I just I keep
hearing like the Friday song in my head
it Black Friday Friday gonna stamp my
Nan's face
gotta save $10 on this rice cooker I
love to see what they're actually
squealing and [ __ ] over in these
videos cuz you don't expect I swear to
God one of them's a rice cooker I swear
but like other countries have
consumerism Europe I actually think the
u.s. is very materialistic more than
other places yeah I don't know what is
it but I feel through the air but you're
right that electronics
that stuff is generally much more
affordable here in America than in
Europe yeah it is you guys may not know
but in Israel for example and I think
the same is true in Europe because
there's like different import taxes and
stuff but a TV that would cost like $300
here in America will cost like 500 in
Israel same with computers and laptops
and cameras and all that [ __ ] shoes
clothing so like we have it our our
wages our general higher I mean people
don't it's hard to find a good paying
job here and and it's more affordable as
it just deals do people just love saving
that they're worth that they're willing
to kick a small child on their nuts I
don't know I don't know it's interesting
it's fascinating now this one is gonna
absolutely shock you this one blew my
socks right off my feet
ela you're not gonna want to miss this
can you tell me what it is they're
fighting over first of all it looks like
a little [ __ ] barbecue or some [ __ ]
or like a bowl like a Tupperware like
yeah but watch just watch what happens I
don't I don't want to interrupt this one
because it's just so pure his kid do you
see this
no did you see this [ __ ] witch pry it
out of this Wow and she's fighting the
grandma Wow why are you being so
aggressive you stole it from the kid she
pried she's like give me this you little
[ __ ] it's like how to jingle all the way
or something so I gotta have a [ __ ]
parody how is this real
daddy exactly this is probably an
otherwise like decent human being with
the family and kids and a husband who
sues stealing [ __ ] from a can people are
literally spilling out on a pile of crap
can we watch it again from beginning to
end as if a nuclear bomb is imminent
okay what is that Dan can you
I know what's worth it's just a pot yeah
something you look it's just some cooker
I swear to god it's just a pan I swear
to you now it's a Teflon pan with a with
a glass top okay imagine that and then
watch this well first of all there's so
much to see here this woman eats [ __ ]
like I haven't eaten that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that since I was like eight watch how
her body sprawled out and she's like oh
my god he just ate [ __ ] but then with
their left arm she's like well at least
I got one of these watch this lady on
the roof there in the green jacket how
as a kid do you understand going on may
be the best video of all time I mean I
could study this this is like well go
down in the history books it's kind of
like playing something like GTA where
you can just mmm
run over people like nothing makes sense
this is almost like a video game like
that right Black Friday's GT and real
friend this kid is just trying to
understand the world he living these are
the most formidable years of a person's
life and some woman just oh my god wait
this is this really well this could be
good action target lady meltdown I don't
think that's really I don't think it's
really a but I have a blog a lot of fun
watching it all right this is man just a
mental breakdown let's let her let's
have her what kind of war I just said
you live on the planet
you live in America the most prosperous
country of all time and you are
you're crushing a child for a [ __ ]
Teflon pan I don't know it's not worth
your dignity what do I wonder is do
these people go home afterwards when
they adrenalin stop pumping you know
when they're when the discounts have
stopped to seduce them do they have a
moment of clarity like an alcoholic
who's like or a drug addict who's like
they come home they sit on their bed and
they're like oh my god what have I
become
no okay
they're just like yes I got the pain no
she's at home cooking let me cook
something now so Damon [ __ ] use it I
don't know have you ever wanted a pan
that much in your life no I don't ever
want any pen just you bite when you need
it you would say that you're so
privileged you don't know what it's like
to need a pan but like just you go home
and you're like I just
what have I done I've grabbed a pant
I've crushed a child what have I done
anyway there's so much more okay
there's so much more we're gonna take
mice yeah that's gonna break yeah a
quick sponsor break thank you to them
who makes the show possible thank you to
watching god bless you I love you so
we'll be back after this brief
commercial break with a ton more of
these great videos are gonna crush your
dreams gonna make you lose all your
faith in humanity and basically not will
have kids and probably castration as
well or not castration but how do you
call it when you tie your tubes you're
gonna chop your balls off
castration all right we'll be right back
thanks guys thank you to me on DS every
year millions of people received the
least like gift of all time you know I
don't wear oh you do know where that is
okay
well listen the family and the friends
they don't want it but we give it to
them anyway and you don't like him
because we hate him yes you look that's
correct but maybe it's not the underwear
that it's the problem
it's the kind of underwear that's right
HeLa let me tell you about me undies
it's the only underwear that makes for
an amazing gift you can give it to
people you actually like and they're
gonna love it too because why EULA model
it's made of modal that's right it's
soft it's flexible it feels like a angel
has grasped your waist line and is
rising you up on its Angely wings to the
pearly gates it's three times softer
than cotton it's natural it's
sustainably sourced fiber okay now
listen me Andes made underwear the
perfect gift that everyone's gonna love
and it's a goddamn holiday miracle they
wrote that by the way do you want to
know seriously guys are about there
there they they they insisted that I use
the Lord's name in vain during a
Christmas wreath and that's how
confident they are and their product and
I'll tell you what I got
angels lifting me to heaven on the skirt
tails of a goddamn me on DS micro modal
this year
don't give them underwear give me undies
so let's add this holiday season get
your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear socks you will ever wear free
shipping 100% satisfaction guaranteed go
to me on DS comm slash age 3 that's me
undies dot-com / h3 thank you so much to
my good friends over at me undies next
up we've got lift oh did you know that
lift knows that their drivers are what
keeps them moving so they do they do
everything they can to make sure their
drivers are happy on every trip guys
it's a simple formula happy drivers mean
happy passengers
maybe that's why 9 out of 10 lyft
drivers I get a perfect five-star rating
now imagine what that's gonna do for
your self-esteem right what are you
doing now you I don't know what what
kind of job you got but imagine you're
driving people around nine out of ten
times they love you and they're gonna
tell you about it too it's a thing it's
not a thing it's a thankful job and we
could all use it's a holiday it's a
goddamn holiday miracle
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips
want to earn more money drive more it's
never been easier to give yourself a
raise lift was the first ride share
platform with tipping built right in
because getting tips shouldn't depend on
your passengers having a crumbled bill
in their pocket I could say that in
support of lyft like Shirou I never
carry cash and I feel bad this great guy
give you know sometimes five stars not
enough sometimes I wanna give the guy
reacharound know what touches genitals
and tell him Shiloh it's a goddamn
Christmas miracle but you keep 100% of
the tips and they add up fast drivers
have been paid out over two hundred
million dollars since the feature was
first introduced twenty percent of it
went to this guy Jeff he's now retired
mm-hmm no I'm kidding but Jeff's dude
he's killing it that was a joke right
those clear and Express pay lets you get
paid almost immediately instead of
waiting for weeks guys lyft has taken
the guesswork out of pickups the new amp
device uses color-coded to help
passengers find their drivers so join
the ride-sharing company that believes
in treating its people better go to lift
calm / h3 today and you can get 500 big
bucks for a new driver bonus that's lyft
l yft Cobb / H 3 4 500 clams limited
time only in terms apply thank you to
our friends that lyft guys get in there
and get high kaptara
thank you to kaptara it's that time of
year again when the days are shorter so
don't waste your precious daylight
sifting through a sea of search results
when looking for the right business
software get home on time tonight with
kaptara
dot-com whether your startup looking to
keep better track of customers a non
profit hoping to have a record
fundraising year or business that simply
needs better payroll software you need
kaptara
and kaptara they've got you covered cap
tears got over 400 categories of
software discover the right tools for
your business
anything from email marketing to
scheduling to accounting and be
on so far beyond you can't even imagine
there's so much going on behind the
scenes I've kept arrow you guys kaptara
makes it easy to find what you're
looking for and they got thousands of
ratings and reviews from actual software
users just like you best of all using
kaptara
is absolutely free that is correct
dealer it's 100% free 2018 will be here
before you know it so make sure you've
got the software your business needs
today
to help you do what you do better join
the millions to use kept air that's Capt
e RR a.com slash h3 that's cap tear Capt
ero Capt erra kaptara did Isis about yes
you guys got it kept here comes lush h3
thank you to kaptara
for sponsoring dear boys and okay
finally thank you to man crates this is
a really interesting company man crates
has gift baskets for men and it to you
really cool stuff in a wood box and they
send you a little crowbar and they says
hey dude you want what's inside you bet
you got to work for it are you a man are
you manna in parent and so yes and it
turns out yes I am a man you did manage
to open it I opened it I got like a car
wash surprise it basically comes with a
shot of testosterone in the form of
opening would with the crowbar I'm just
like oh my god yeah yeah I started
flexing in the mirror it's really hard
to pick out the perfect gift but all too
easy to totally get it wrong introducing
man crate calm the surest way to find
gifts that guys will actually love
guaranteed this isn't a cheese of the
Month Club or a new tie Oh
shots fired watch out new tie guys man
crates offer over 100 hand curated gift
collections for every type of guy from
the rugged outdoorsman to the sports
fanatic and everything in between
for example whiskey appreciation crepe
with a
personalized D cancer in glasses for his
favorite drink or a grillmaster crate
with brass knuckle meat tenderizers
tenderizers you put on brass knuckles
you punch me forget it did and a
cast-iron smoker box Jessica just go to
man crate comm pick the perfect grate
and choose the delivery date it rhymes
I didn't know they rode this in prose
our poetry would be really guys listen
you may not have known this about man
crepe but both men's health and Allure
magazine are saying man crate are the
perfect gift for men and those who don't
agree on everything and those two don't
agree on anything they said I didn't
realize there was Asian
apparently there's a huge rivalry
between men's health and Allure magazine
about so man crate is stuck in the
middle of this beef but they've squashed
it because man crate is so great they
got thousands of five-star reviews and
every man Craig comes with a 100%
satisfaction guaranteed what's the link
the link is go to man crate Kampf /h
three four five percent off your order
one more time that's five percent off at
man crates calm man crates with an S at
the end man crates dot cab slash age
three I had a lot of fun with man crates
it's a it's a hoot and a holler go check
it out the man in your life will be on
his knees thanking you thank you so much
guys and now back to the story welcome
back to the h3 podcast we were just
talking about stomping on children's
faces to save $10 on rice cookers we've
got a call an anecdote from somebody who
has a story for us let's take a call
from Eli Eli you're on the air what's up
what's up you got a story about Black
Friday yeah so like it was a long time
ago me my brother were both like big
playstation people
and when I was a little there before we
had anything like that our uncle had a
ps3 one day like we were like oh that
like that knew been like a Batman games
awesome so he went to Black Friday to go
get this game right and I was like
really little right maybe like a six or
seven or something like that right we
were there trying to find the game and
this like old lady she was probably six
year to 70 right she thought I was
trying to take a purse right and she
grabbed my face and she had those long
like fake nails that was people would
like to get right and she left a huge
scratch on the side of my god like shoot
I was like like like it broke the skin I
was bleeding my uncle got pissed my
brother got pinched it almost started
like a riot at like this car get I love
it man it wasn't saying that was like
the first time I've gone to black market
I mean is Black Friday and so pakmar's
I'm just scared so you haven't been back
since yeah but it sounds you have some
badass like superhero scars on your face
now though yeah who did you say just
clawed me in the face on Black Friday
but you can still see the scars wow man
yet listen you may have left
empty-handed but a souvenir you're an
American Hero yeah your hero man thanks
for braving that old lady all the way we
got that game one hand on my scars
holding the blob your hand on the game I
was run to that check out bro you were
in the trenches man taking me lady
Handan your all-american hero thank you
for sharing your story I was like
crawling around hidin oh yeah nice angle
I love you too bro things okay let's see
we have another call from Davin he
apparently grandma knocked him over and
grabbed a box of diapers from him
diapers
[ __ ] I'm curious now Devin tell me about
the diapers yeah I want to know about
the diapers
dude it was one of the most craziest
things I've ever experienced you know of
it like going up as like growing up as
like a kid and in looking usually normal
and then just you know grabbing a box of
diapers and not thinking anything of it
then having this random wacko come up
and just knock you over for some diapers
what was you know Ellen that you really
just like hit you hard as a kid do you
remember what was the deal on the
diapers yeah I don't even think there
was a deal on the diapers it might have
been like 50% off but nothing very no
like laid out a hit over it's like the
apocalypse like where was it or was
there a riot going on at the time was
was this during the LA riots no it was
literally just a regular Black Friday it
was like a few years back like I wasn't
even that old maybe like 9 or 10 and my
parents were like hey just go get the
diapers just like no problem they said
you want to solo me you never forget did
you came back as a man well that's
beautiful man thanks for sharing that
I was really poetic appreciate you god
bless you mm-hmm Cooper Cooper by app um
well it's tough out there on Black
Friday
Ainge age ain't nothing but a number
that's right 70 take its number break
your hip six formative years you'll
never be the same age ain't nothing but
a number well said you here's a great
one my favorites this there's this one's
really good I like it just like God
first of all let me do it on a favor
both these [ __ ] again these guys they
make these annotations they know how to
put them where you can't ever close them
and YouTube in their infinite wisdom is
like this is okay anyway I'll forget
about that for now listen closely in the
background as a woman screams as if her
child was just crushed under a sledge
hammer listen to this
[Music]
did you hear that yeah who says if the
pits of hell had opened up oh my god is
this hell on earth
no just Walmart's Walmart Blackburn
[Music]
watch this down the road Super Saiyan
man have you ever seen I don't know that
beyond the fields of battle in Iraq or
Afghanistan
and modern day can you see anyone exert
themselves with such urgency and power
and resolution as you see this kind of
that right here Reese isn't that guy
this guy he's like see ya idiot he's
just into the ground people don't even
give me [ __ ] either
man man
growing up in rural America is [ __ ]
weird soon bro and then he's just back
at the Lin hey let's go home and watch
your new TV guys when we were Walmart
right well Martin right they should put
this on the jumbotron as they chant that
remember who we are you know when we
were there looking for sales I was like
man do they have any like anti anti
acids on sale I wonder if they have a
showstopper on their tums they didn't
they did I looked and like will you take
for your acid reflux like did I don't
want I don't want a we I just want a
feeling some tums I'm gonna stock up on
some tums um that one's pretty great
what else you got DJ so in my research
this was actually really surprising and
a lot of fun and relevant as well
speaking about Patrice Wilson for those
of you who don't know he's the
mastermind behind Rebecca Black's Friday
mm-hmm and we all remember it's Friday
okay and so I was typed Black Friday and
I sorted by top views and I spent a long
time going through that list I found
possibly the most carnage I've seen in a
video and that would be Rebecca Black
Friday acoustic version with 7.2 million
views on ABC News featuring Rebecca
Black and your boy Patrice Wilson oh my
god
life comes at you fast maybe seeing your
ABC [ __ ] news bro
this [ __ ] is pure carnage if you lost
faith in humanity watching that glady
rip the box from that blues young boys
and you ain't seen nothing
acoustic version ABC News my friends
this is it 7.5 million views look who's
there I'd rather watch a grown man
[Music]
stomp a [ __ ] child
for an Xbox this is a this is a car
wreck is blood everywhere how many
people had strokes watching this how
many people died falling victim to this
video yeah I got a chorus let's say
calling answering fun fun fun
so anyway that's a thing on the internet
I thought you guys might appreciate
great song there's like all these
theatres oh wait
yo these are Patricia's other little
angels
these are Patrice's angels no wonder
they're so into it that could be me
someday
yeah those were Patrice's glory days man
when uh when friday was huge he was on
top of the world he was like a genius
hailed as a genius so chillin in the
back seat now he's on the outside in the
word
he's an upside-down world stalking my
ass like a [ __ ] what were those
monsters called in change he's a Gorger
on courgette on this is my Gorga on he's
stalking my ass anyway that's the thing
sorry sorry you guys
I'd rather watch Isis execution videos
no okay so what's next on the playlist
up next up next on the list is a sorry
II listen I fix our tails in a stampede
choppers falling to the ground
choppers charged ahead fixated on
doorbuster deals thirteen-year-old girl
helping a pregnant woman get up this but
really save me people Walmarts this lady
gets not to the ground near to the
ground it's measure width up in the
morning just like several people falling
to the
putting the wig back on is priority
before being trampled to death
she gotta look fabulous if she's gonna
die she better look good
I'm shoppers charged ahead like they are
literally storming Normandy I just loved
that ground near Grand Rapids Michigan
had five in the morning despite several
people falling to the ground his charm
was charged get up had to be taken away
by ambulance another woman who was
injured was taken to the hospital her
husband blame the store for a lack of
security yes so it's like people are
risking their lives when they go out on
Black Friday
I mean basic I never thought about it
like that but I just wanted to show you
the want the lady's wig falling off with
it though that was heartwarming we're
doing the target song we will show them
that we are not just the best store in
this neighborhood but the best store
anywhere
we are the lannisters swinging from the
think it's a parity of like 300 okay
and collect your checks for $75 on your
way out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he's a jolly guy the best of it so we
our target nope
which Walmart that was target the
Walmart chant well my question to you is
since your good evening oh my god so
just a few moments we're gonna open up
these doors and people from all over the
world bro are they can you spend on the
floor and you will engage in the largest
sales day probably in the history of the
world okay now that Sinkin you're part
of history right now those Playstations
they're marked down 15 bucks this is the
largest sale in the history of this
planet okay this guy is cents not much
since you more about this I genuinely
think target sent to memoy to the store
managers to climb up on a tabletop and
give a prep speech sandwich to increase
the stock of this company by point two
percent right I'm - I'm - uh - cynical
sorry it's the bile stuck in my throat
[Laughter]
so here is one outside
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] this is Urban
Outfitters do not get in between
fifteen-year-old girls and their $5
leggings that's a lot of people bro
what's more terrifying this or like
paratroopers just just buy online I like
I like Black Friday online it's like
yeah safe peaceful I guess some people
like the adrenaline rush I guess you
know oh my got a elbow in the face today
hmm and get away with it your mouse well
if you're not right in the front like
what are you gay you kid it's probably
literally a thousand people on land
outside the gate they're squealing now
they're tearing down the game they've
got this theft detectors they're being
it's like a tsunami everything is going
with this tsunami but these detectors
are being ripped asunder that's crazy
what is wrong with this planet man I
mean genuinely it seriously I don't know
does Urban Outfitters even do like crazy
sales I don't think so apparently that's
probably not that crazy probably up
Tom's on sale something you know me and
he did go to Black Friday once we went
one time and it was though well let me
tell you it's got a twist ending this is
when we were living in Santa Cruz and we
were super poor mm-hmm and our laptop
that my parents had bought me for
college started dying and we're like
dude we're so [ __ ] broke man like I
remember we had no TV like that was yeah
they're our only source of entertainment
we used to watch Seinfeld on a stream
that looped every
episode on that thing that was our only
source of entertainment and we were so
bored remember we spent like a full day
seeing what was the best value we could
get for like $300 mm-hmm I was like to
the Black Friday's coming up like let's
let's cop one of these deals and so we
were looking on Best Buy and like man
this is a great [ __ ] deal for 300
bucks is the best deal in town we got
war let's go let's actually go do it it
was crazed crazy idea right I'm like man
I don't want to be one of those people
but hell I was also curious because I've
never it was my first time right in the
states and so we are lazy as [ __ ] dude
we mean you we were sleeping into like
well not you you used to wake up early
but we would sleep in when we weren't
work in because we woke up at like 3:30
we left to go to Best Buy to be first in
line pitchblack mill the night freezing
cold we pull up there's nobody there
like what the [ __ ] are we just are we
dead insane people who like camp out and
wait in line so we get out of the car we
go up to the front this lights are off
in this store nobody's even there I'm
like okay I guess we're even crazier
than the employees and we're like a
whole like what is today Friday we went
on Thanksgiving must have been how sad
is that much we didn't even know us
Thanksgiving I think I didn't understand
him what Black Friday was so we went on
the wrong day we woke our asses up at
3:30 went all the way there how stupid
and then we went and got some burritos
that were that was the whole thing
Salty's we got burritos went to sleep
both woke up in the middle of the night
super thirsty like we've never drank
water before great anecdote we didn't go
there next day that we bought online
yeah very happy with that but man that
was embarrassing huh yeah probably for
the best I would have probably need some
kid in the
face and bid in prison or something um
here watch this one this is my final
Black Friday video oh I keep talking
about like warfare and like trenches and
stuff and how it resembles like an
invasion and this part really struck me
as such watch this guy here in the
ground
Amir Lee spills everybody eat [ __ ] look
at this guy scrambling out of the way
for dear [ __ ] life like he's in the
trenches taking grades yes
everyone's like wool wool wool people in
the floor you think that would stop them
no people immediately start eating [ __ ]
survive I'm pretty sure a couple years
ago some old lady literally died dan can
you do some research how many fatalities
have happened on Black Friday
I'd like to know that meanwhile that's
about all I got about that and so I get
out there you know whatever it takes
$5 save that whatever the hell it takes
you guys something do we got a call on
deck nope
so next up are you saying you had that
current what is it like Friday discord
well you sent me a death count are you
[ __ ] kidding me there's a website
called Black Friday death count jeez
holy [ __ ] dude this website is awesome
somebody already thought of this Black
Friday death count 10 deaths 107
injuries 10 deaths it's got all the
details honorable mentions this guy's
serious as hell let's skip those we got
a lot of data in 2016
San Antonio man helped a woman being
beaten in a Walmart parking lot shot
dead shopper opens fire killing one over
Walmart parking spot they didn't even
get a chance to get in the store they
were killing each other over parking
spots
Black Friday kicks off with deadly
shooting at near June New Jersey mall I
was from 2016 2013 teen returns home
from Black Friday shopping fell asleep
at wheel killed in Rack will do that in
I'll throw that in I mean you know woke
up early father crashed father charged
in crash that killed daughters after
Black Friday shopping that is truly
awful my god can you imagine getting a
car crash your daughter is dying then
you go to prison for it it's like okay I
guess my life is just completely and
permanently [ __ ]
you went from elbowing some old lady in
the face for a rice cooker Black Friday
target shoppers step over Walter Vance
who the [ __ ] is Walter Vance was so
specific they step over a guy as he
collapse and dies Jesus ah warms your
heart in it Southern California tires
arrest shooting leaves two dead was with
all these shootings at Toys R Us in well
places toys are not apparently killing
people RS all right mm-hmm
all right yes unlike the bullets those
hit worker dies at Long Island Walmart
after being trampled in Black Friday
Stampede bro that's so sick this poor
this poor son of a [ __ ]
working 3 a.m. at Walmart gets trampled
to death Oh Patrice ok Patrice is on a
livestream kick I'll take a quick I'll
take a quick look trees Wilson use if I
can resist
apparently there's some [ __ ] going down
here oh okay the top note keeps getting
yeah he keeps blocking out the thumbnail
making a creepier and creepier and it
just clearly says 666 h3 why is everyone
getting alarmed
Patrice what do you got for me this week
and he also had this website called
social media networks calm bro what are
you even playing this even your voice
like like we just saw there were creepy
shots littered throughout the stream and
an almost he's playing other people's
way what this aint creepy Patrice you
just broke the wall that's [ __ ]
anymore yeah what is he showing someone
else's video about the strip yeah did
did find a trailer what was he doing Dan
for a news show I'd forget about it
he's trying to promote a show you blow
it capisce um apparently he was showing
clips of me making fun of him okay
that's a death threat here's a story
that came up recently that really pissed
me off
uber these sickos man I don't know if
you guys heard about this story a
hackers broke into burrs database and
stole everybody's data drivers
passengers everybody's data and they
covered it up for a whole [ __ ] year
mm-hm and didn't tell anybody
fifty-seven million people data stolen
that's crazy bro people are calling my
number all the time and I'm like how are
people getting my number Instagram was
hacked and they leaked numbers
apparently on verified accounts now all
the sudden I found out a year ago
uber leaked everybody's data and they
didn't even say anything formed our like
gear actively trying to hide
- so the hackers had all this data and
they demanded $100,000 ransom that uber
paid and they wrote it off as a
deduction for a bug bounty mm-hmm these
Psychopaths I'm getting so tired of all
these companies just like playing
willy-nilly with everyone's data and
then nothing happens
that's a serious breach of private
privacy what happen with Equifax were
they leaking like social security
numbers of like half of Americans and
they're like yeah can you do we just had
it in a plain text file in a doc that
said social security numbers we nobody
could have seen this coming I'm ready to
bring out the guillotine maybe not that
far but things that you have no option
you gotta use this services what are you
gonna not use Instagram you're gonna not
use uber but that's what's so [ __ ] like
that's why we need regulations yeah you
can't trust these sons of [ __ ] and
there's not even a fair competition like
there's there's not that many companies
doing it it's not like there's millions
of options to choose from like Equifax
it's like like sorry just [ __ ] down your
open mouth what are you gonna do about
it
idiot but the fact they waited a whole
freaking year and didn't say anything in
find that's so insane I'm lit I'm
deleting goober I'm I've removed the app
for my phone I'm using lyft now.com
slash h3 I'm only using lyft calm slash
h3 now because they respect my data and
they treat their drivers great but like
dude we can't support these companies
who play us like this I know but it's
I'm just saying you have no option what
are you gonna delete Instagram no I love
Instagram
yeah they could just leak pictures of my
dick and I'd be like Oh
well I wonder what you'll oppose today
but that kind of brings me into the next
story that I want to talk about which
the next net neutrality which is once
again up for debate everyone's trying to
[ __ ] it what net neutrality for the
hundredth time everyone complains then
the politicians and the telecom
companies are like this is the first
time we've talked about this everyone
who talks like we did a whole podcast
about net neutrality yeah recently and
there's always people who dissent who
disagree because I guess the the
counter-argument is that the less
regulations the better the more free
market right mm-hmm
and so companies that decide to use the
tenets of net neutrality will have more
business you let the market decide but
you'll have like three companies Comcast
in many places is the only fricking
place you can get internet or they have
like dummy companies where Comcast has
like normal first world internet speed
and then you have another one called
like Lowell only idiots buy the [ __ ]
that has like dial-up speed that they
just have it there so it doesn't seem
like a monopoly mm-hmm it's so
frustrating dude it's just like a battle
of misinformation let me show you this
[ __ ] Orwellian [ __ ] that um verizon
tweeted this out and immediately I was
like they're gonna delete this this is
the dumbest garbage I've ever seen you
know what they're calling this bill to
repeal net neutrality this is some 1984
[ __ ] the restoring Internet Freedom Act
mm-hmm it's so confusing and so people
who believe in like more conservative
doctrines of not regulating markets you
get so confused by the name restoring
Internet Freedom Act it's so insidious
seriously confusing I was confused when
I saw that article that you're gonna
show right it's not it's not cool let me
explain for people who don't understand
we're like I don't believe in net
neutrality because whatever
net neutrality literally only says that
telecom companies cannot regulate the
internet it's literally a regulation to
make it free mm-hmm it's a little
counterintuitive but that's what it is
okay and so restoring the Internet
freedom act freedom for them to
basically up charge you it's just your
speed and do everything on it's like
they're making fun of you when they call
it totally because reasonably repealing
net neutrality benefits about a thousand
people the owners and stock shares of
these telecom companies that's it versus
three hundred plus million Americans you
know look at this here this was their
tweet the day erased I [ __ ] saved it
on my phone like these it is remove this
they said we support the FCC's uh
[Music]
restoring Internet freedom
yeah restoring Internet freedom and I
commented something like of course you
do you paid for it because they spent
tens of millions of dollars lobbying to
repeal net neutrality anyway I can't
read all this garbage but they try to
make it seem like they're doing this
great thing or even worse that we agree
with you mmm-hmm we're on your we all
agree on this we all want a free and
open Internet that's why we're storing
the Internet Freedom Act you know so and
then Comcast literally Hitler by the way
like when you search Comcast and SC
swastika comes up look at the balls on
these lunatics Comcast we this out we do
not and will not block throttle or
discriminate against lawful content we
will continue to make sure that our
policies are clear transparent for
consumers we will not change our
commitment to these principles here's
the picture we won't walk we won't
throttle we won't we will be bad we yeah
you get I said they're wrong that's
basically like Hitler saying I won't I
swear to God I will not invade Poland
comcast has been the most hated and
distrusted company in all of the world
for like many years right why is it that
you think if they're so down with the
tenants of net neutrality why is it that
you that they spend tens of million
dollars every year lobbying to repeal it
yeah if you believe it then what's the
[ __ ] problem it's there already I'm
so over it
it's so [ __ ] frustrating you have to
have this conversation every other month
yeah every once a month I see net
neutrality trending on Twitter and I'm
like oh what happened this month
it's like they break you down they grind
you down until you can't talk about
anymore because people are tired of
listening to it I'm tired of talking
people are tired of listening to me talk
about it it's [ __ ] sick and it's a
game that they play it's a calculated
game they spend money it's their hedging
their bets and they're buying senators
and governors and they're confusing
people into thinking that they're voting
in their favor
look at this Comcast tweet like here I I
comment tweet retweeted it let me show
you like one comment in particular that
shows you like the confusion that
they're sowing in people's minds with
all with this 1984 double-talk one of
the comments is like I'm confused here's
one of the top comments 44 likes I'm
confused now that a company's showing
that they support what we're all
fighting for you're labeling them as
Hitler am I missing something here yes
and as in they're intentionally doing
that's a confusion yeah we we fully
support net neutrality as they spend
millions to get it repealed [ __ ] so
frustrating dude it's like they're just
in the end it feels like inevitable
they're just gonna win cuz how you know
how can we keep fighting the same [ __ ]
forever how when does it end it ends
when they win that's it like we already
won once oh bomb
Pass net neutrality laws and we want and
now [ __ ] out we're staying back in
the same stupid-ass situation it's like
the last free medium and the whole world
is the last true democratic medium I'm
wondering well what happened in the rest
of the world if it changes here it will
follow it will follow right most
definitely it will follow because I mean
maybe maybe some governments like maybe
some some countries and the populace are
educated enough to know that it's that
it's all a bunch of crap problem with
America's there's way too many people
there's way too much information there's
way too much confusion nobody knows what
the [ __ ] going on when you have a
country like den I don't Norway for
example they've like five million people
there so it's much easier if everyone to
under kind of understand and educate
themselves there's less diversity of
opinion and less polarized here it's
like this part party politic is like if
you're a conservative or right winger
it's it's it's on your party line to
support net neutrality and there's just
there you don't you and that's just all
there is to it you support your team
well I'm sick of it anyway it's my
prediction is that it's it's gonna pass
and we're all [ __ ] because they're
just you can't fight this fight forever
they grinding you down man she it so in
that note
it's a battle of misinformation and
confusion and we are gonna lose and
listen at the end of the day all that
matters is that next year a year from
today I can kick a little [ __ ]
toddler in the face I can punt his ass
three yards and save $20 on a TV as long
as I can kick a a infant without
repercussion because it's in the chaos
and the mayhem then you can control my
internet you can monitor me you can open
my phone and watch me jerk off record my
screen all the weird porn I watch you
know they do that
and someday when I'm trying to run for
for a governor or some [ __ ] they'd be
like Ethan are you sure dude I saw you
watching that preggo puke porn man we
have footage of it mom be like alright
[ __ ] I'm out
mm-hmm I'm not gonna run it's not worth
it they got us all by the balls but we
can [ __ ] elbow the little babies in
the face and then finally we got one
other really cool thing to talk about
h3h street dlc payday 2 yeah
Bros there's this game payday 2 if you
don't know what it is one of the most
popular PC games super [ __ ] fun
multiplayer game these guys over at Star
breeze and overkill we've been talking
them for how long has it been like six
months to a year or something yeah since
April Fool's it all started
April Fool's they started by making a
joke about that they were putting us in
the game as a DLC playable characters
but everybody liked it mm-hmm
and so like [ __ ] it let's do it so we
flew out to Sweden in a while ago you
guys may remember we were planning all
the DLC with these guys came back since
then we've been doing like hours of
voiceover recording it's been a ton of
work and we're really proud of the work
we did actually it's run on payday 2 it
was so much fun man [ __ ] we put us in
the [ __ ] game scares the [ __ ] I can
ride so scary it's my their heads a
little [ __ ] them um my 4 is not that big
is it anyway there's like so many voice
lines they give us this really cool
freaking perk deck and gun um
weapon is there is a ruler that's my
melee weapon yeah it's from the two hand
that a great sword
I don't me play some lines for you guys
so who put a ball I would have started a
long time ago this guy actually when got
all of them in the game is success hey
dude I got like half a soda pop in the
fridge if you want it
kind of embarrassing that is so fifties
um I was just zoning out thinking about
chicken wings chicken sorry about that
it's okay control I was just combing my
hair keep the civilians calm guys be
nice
alright keep the civilians calm now hey
I have to be like somewhat serious when
we're doing cuz yeah they don't want us
to absolutely destroy the game cuz it is
about bank robbers and they have like a
whole community that follows this game
in a very serious community yeah so they
didn't want to upset the people there
were not fans of ours total me so it had
to be like a good mix of meme non meme
right but here's the best part
ela shouting and [ __ ] people up I
swear I saw one other guy talking to his
gun or something well this Bane guy ever
show up here I don't want to get you in
the gunfight man yeah on me follow come
with me but people look but it's
available you want to play it the base
game 75% off on Steam the h3h3 DLC is
out we are gonna make a HC video about
it soon it's gonna be a la hood I'll
holler a gaff above us boof a slam
anyway guys listen do we have any other
calls guess not
poor Ian's been taking all these [ __ ]
calls he only got two only to pass the
grade
I wonder how many people how many how
many people have you talked to today and
would you guess my people have you hung
up on about 40 [ __ ] you college gotta
step your [ __ ] up man
only school got through out of 40 and
it's the Great Firewall man all the
caller's hate in he's great I love you
man he's in the trenches literally
taking grenades you know we're only
gonna take questions
we can't I can imagine a lot of people
just want to say hi and yeah sure
apparently they're like people are
calling be like when it's Teddy fresh
restock coming here it's like it's not
the purpose of this phone call but god
bless you anyway yeah anyway guys thank
you for spending this Friday with us
it's been an absolute joy it's been a
privilege and a pleasure I'm sorry that
Bert Kreischer was not here but I hope
you enjoyed this face stomping elbow
throwing Bach fried Black Friday
extravaganza and I will show the very
best I love you all very very much
next week we have very excited jontron
finally probably one of the most highly
requested guests yes finally coming on
the show
this Wednesday it's at an unusual hour
it's yeah it's on Wednesday I'm gonna
put up a thread right after this ends
for questions for him so go there and
put your questions for a good old John
Oh Johnny boy
chant Rand so guys I'll see you then and
I love you so I love you I want to see
you all naked
I want a carrot shaved I want the tub of
mayonnaise do you know what comes next
your eyes look like hamburgers oh wow
that's a beautiful love song that girl
with hamburgers in her eyes
am i right that anyway guys have a great
weekend
you know if you were here let me tell
you ela close your eyes cover your ears
pure love thanks for joining us that was
a lot of fun guys a great weekend have a
great weekend guys
Tata